traverser l'atlantique en moins de cinq
heures c'est la tempête keira qui a
rendu l'exploit possible pour deux
transporteurs des inondations de la
neige et surtout du vent qui rend a
provoqué de nombreux dégâts en europe
avec ses rafales allant jusqu'à 180
km/heure une partie du trafic aérien a
été perturbé et ses vents ont fait le
bonheur de british airways qui a
fracassé des records
il a fallu que 4h56 over 112 parties de
new york le 8 février pour atteindre
londres 1h20 plus tôt que prévu le
courant jet huisne poucet l'appareil ce
qui lui a permis d'atteindre une vitesse
de pointe de 1327 kilomètres à l'heure
deux avions de virgin atlantic ont aussi
fait cette liaison en moins de cinq
heures le vol transatlantique le plus
rapide de l'histoire remonte à 1996 un
concorde l'avait fait en moins de trois
heures
[Musique]